[Music]
hey you guys what's up
yeah there's a person in the damn
comment section called
the unmasked phantom of the opera with
hair
that's it as i saw that i laughed i love
[ __ ] up screams
i'll watch another show and what kind of
regular commenters are doing in
krakolactika
[Laughter]
that's pretty oh awesome yeah
all right so excuse me goodness
uh yeah so what is it it's tuesday today
right
yeah we actually ended up not doing a
food show this week but that's okay
we'll do another one next yeah i don't
want to talk about food right now
when we think of something well so well
and like i said um we were we were
signed on movies we were yeah and
actually uh dermot
uh dermot hennessey who's in the
comments sometime i don't know if he's
in there right now
he um actually sent me i mentioned
brimstone and treacle and he sent me the
money for bernstein and treacle and also
uh vincent price's theater of blood
which we will be reviewing at some point
also
yeah we don't do these in order that you
guys send it to them we do them in the
order that we feel like doing
that we feel like watching them so it
gets kind of [ __ ] up you know i mean
uh
we got a big stack we got to get to
we'll get to them eventually
well i mean ever since we started doing
the older ones on the matinee that makes
it a lot easier because you know then we
don't have to wait
like because the movie retrospectives
were just once a week you know this
movie here is a good one
forgotten classic it's called brimstone
and treacle
which you know and it's it's a very
mysterious movie
it's fun to watch and we're going to get
into it it's got the stars sting
yeah and he does a [ __ ] great job and
he sting can act
makes you want to see his version of
frankenstein now
i haven't seen the bride in a really
long time but as i said
um i was watching in search of darkness
that horror documentary
and they were talking about it on there
and it made me like all nostalgic
because i saw the bride probably like 50
bajillion times when i was a kid
it's like i don't know if it still holds
up but i remember really liking it back
then yeah yeah yeah
so i think this was the second only the
second movie that sting had done
after quadrophenia and in quadrophenia
he wasn't like really the main character
he was kind of a side character
so he's kind of like the main character
in this one so the story behind this one
you know okay so you know what's funny
about this so this is uh this was
written by dennis potter
um you know a really uh well-known
british writer now prior to even hearing
a brims and a treacle
i had actually read the singing
detective i think my ex-husband gave it
to me actually
i saw the movie adaptation i think
robert downey jr was in it it was all
right it wasn't that great the book was
much better
i had seen pennies from heaven which
again is a pretty decent adaptation
but the weird thing about that this is
that i hadn't seen this one
and then do you remember like many years
ago you just like woke up one morning
randomly
and you said for some reason i was just
thinking of this movie that i saw
a long time ago and you kind of
described it and i was kind of like man
that doesn't sound familiar and then
you're like oh
sting was in it so then we did a google
search and we found it
yeah and then we were able to like find
it and watch it and i was like how the
[ __ ] did i never see this movie yeah i
saw it
i saw it sometimes when i was in the
army yeah but i didn't
or when i got out of the army i don't
remember around that time yeah
and it it tripped me it was when i got
out
eric eric grock showed this to me oh
okay
he was he was into uh like movies from
this era
yeah and music from that era yeah and he
pulled this one out
and i watched it it was it was a trip
it's about this dude
with the mysterious origin he's played
by sting a young guy
he comes out of a church and he just
starts randomly
approaching dudes oh i know you you know
pretend like he
he knows him and he tries to talk his
way back into this dude's life talk his
way into his house
and take all his [ __ ] from him that's
what it seems like
but as the story unfolds there's like
more to it
he's some kind of a supernatural
creature he's must be a demon
but then this but then as it goes on is
he a demon or is he an angel
because he seems to be doing good things
and bad things at the same time to serve
an ultimate good
but he's bad it's a weird like he does
bad things but it turns out
which is like really really kind of
[ __ ] up which i think okay so
the history of this so dennis potter
initially wrote this
as a teleplay for bbc they were gonna
show
this was back in 1976 and they were
going to show it on the show that they
had back then play for today so they
were going to do it like you know a
stage play but like on tv
so they produced it um and the bbc were
like yeah no i don't think we could show
that um
because from everything i've heard i
haven't seen the uh the bbc version even
though like mango said it was better
the bbc version is a little more extreme
and i think that the bbc version please
correct me if i'm wrong because mega
said that he had seen it
um i think it's less ambiguous
in the in the bbc version that
uh martin taylor the character played by
sting in the movie
is the devil yeah um i think in the
stage play he even
has or he even has like hooves and
[ __ ] like that like cloven hooves i
think that's what i that's what i heard
he might just be a demon then yeah not
really the devil per se
yeah it's almost kind of like it it's
only he almost comes across as like a
trickster
god a little bit so way i
interpreted it demons are angels
they're just fallen angels yeah the the
difference between a demon and an angel
is very subtle
and when you watch the movie you kind of
see that demonic things are happening
but kind of so are angelic things
he's doing good things but he's bad
yeah and then he does some bad things
and good comes from it it's weird
which i think was what was kind of
controversial i think most of the
controversy arose at least from what i
could determine
because they thought that i think their
main problem
was that they thought that religious
people would be offended um
you know this was back in the 70s yeah
the theme is faith
pretty much and the thing about it too
is it's almost kind of like
something that i got from because i've
seen this a couple of times and then we
just like watched it again like last
night another thing i got from it too
was that the two characters
like the husband and wife who in the
movie are named tom and norma i think
her name is amy in the stage play but it
doesn't really matter she's the same
character otherwise
and her being sort of like not
simple-minded necessarily but she's a
very simple woman she you know she has
very strong faith she's a very positive
she believes in miracles she believes in
the good of people
whereas her husband tom is just like
this bitter
old you know kind of cranky [ __ ]
and you know he's lost his faith because
of what happened with the daughter which
like i said we'll get into the plot in a
minute
but so it's almost kind of like they're
seeing the world
the way that they are like they're
projecting whatever their [ __ ] is onto
the world at large because she is a good
person so she sees the world as a good
place
and she sees this guy's again and she
sees this guy as a good guy even though
he's doing bad things and he is helping
her and he's taking advantage of her but
it does
actually end up helping her in the end
yeah and he does do her work for her
yeah he did fix her marriage in a way
or at least got her to realize it
exposed it so she could kick his stupid
ass out
but it's just like i i think the problem
i what
most people would probably find more
shocking nowadays than the religious
stuff
is the fact okay so well let's talk
about the plot a little bit
so in the movie version sting like you
said he plays his character named martin
taylor now he comes out of a church at
the beginning and he starts like
approaching dudes in the street like
pretending like he knows them like i
said so
he's like a con man and he's trying to
like con his way into
people's lives yeah and hold on what's
that during the during the opening
credits
it shows a bunch of messages and words
the cr the titles and the
the you know what i mean like uh with
the opening titles or
credits comes out of the mouth
of a photograph of a gargoyle yeah
so i was kind of interpreting it and
then it shows him walking out
of the doors of a church i was kind of
interpreting it as
he had come from the mouth of a gargoyle
but he had also come from a church so
it's ambiguous
he came from the mouth of good or he
came from the mouth of evil
yeah yeah well that's what's so
fascinating i'm not sure is that
morality
isn't black and white it's like yes he
did terrible things right
like objectively terrible things yeah
but the result of them was not
necessarily bad
no he even saves the the daughter yes
got a head injury and been in a
vegetative state basically
basically vegetative so that's what ends
up happening is that
he so he's been trying to do this with
you know with dudes in the street so he
finally gets this guy
uh named tom bates and he is able to
sort of wangle his way
into like i think tom like tries to
escape him but he steals his wallet so
he knows where he lives so he
turns up back at his house like hey man
you lost your wallet you know he deals
the money too
yeah he did steal the money but even
though he says somebody else did it yeah
but um so he's in there and he begins to
ingratiate himself into
the household by saying that he was
the boyfriend of their daughter patricia
now three years previously patricia had
been hit by a truck
right and she's still alive but she's
you know
like a vegetable yeah she's not in a
coma she can still like make noises and
move around and stuff but it's like
she's not they're not really sure like
she's like infantile
yeah they're not really sure like what's
going on in there she can't talk anymore
and there's like um so so tom and norma
kind of have these terrible like fights
about norma is convinced that she'll get
better someday that she can understand
what norma
is saying to her and tom is just like
you know she's gone
that's there's nothing you i don't know
why you're being so silly and so stupid
there's no god there's no anything and
it's like
yeah he his job is to write these
eulogies see he appears very religious
but he doesn't believe in any of it
yeah and he doesn't believe in any of it
because he just he thinks if there is a
god it's indifferent or it's kind of
cruel
um he lost his faith uh
it turns out later he's also a pervy
[ __ ] too he's
he doesn't appear to be but he's a
[ __ ] pervy [ __ ]
he appears to be kind of real uptight
and
conservative but no he he's a hoe well
yeah because not only is he banging his
secretary
yeah um he also there's a scene of him
too like where he
thinks about stopping to pick up a a
young teenager teenage girl she was
trying
and she was trying to get in the car and
it rained it was raining yeah and then
he sped up again and was like dirty [ __ ]
or something like that and it turns out
he was digging through
the daughter's [ __ ] underwear his
daughter's on turn looking at the bra
she's not just being her father
yeah i'm just like um no that's not how
that works
so yeah like that's kind of so that kind
of comes out
uh through martin being there because
obviously you know tom being a cranky
old
dude and i don't he doesn't want all his
secrets
sort of uh you know exposed i guess yeah
though
he really does not want this individual
here however
martin taylor is very very good at
ingratiating himself with norma
because norma has not been able to leave
the house since patricia has been in the
ashes she has not left the house in
three
years because she you know she's her
full-time caretaker
yes he starts buttering her up calling
her mom and [ __ ]
mumsy mumsy yeah of course stings
he's he's in this movie he's [ __ ]
young and he's very
charming and good-looking he kind of
comes across as like uh
what's that other actor it's malcolm
mcdowell like in a clockwork orange yeah
kind of actually a little bit better
looking than malcolm again he reminded
me very much of it
yeah but you're much of [ __ ] crazy
ass malcolm mcdowell
and [ __ ] norma it's probably
probably about jenny's age actually but
with the hair and the clothes
and just the style of england in the
[ __ ] 80s it was like some other 50s
she looks like she's she looks like
she's in her 70s or 60s but now she's
probably like in her late 40s
and he's just buttering her up and she's
attracted to him
you can tell but she's such a good
person she doesn't
realize this attraction i don't think
she tries to keep it
i guess she tries to keep it well he
appeals
clean and he's like trying to come out
through the motherly
yeah thing and he appeals to her through
her vanity she he
um appeals to her because her husband
doesn't understand her
doesn't understand how much work she has
to do all day i mean her job is 24 7
taking care of
the girl yeah um so he starts doing all
the ch all the job
yeah so he starts cooking and cleaning
and all this other stuff however
he also starts molesting
the the girl the the girl yeah she's hot
she just because she's paralyzed
you know whatever she's [ __ ] up she's
not she can't she's real good looking
and
her body is looking intact she's just ah
like that and it's funny you know what i
mean he's
you don't know it's ambiguous it's it's
it's kind of like molestation
oh it definitely is patient because
it came from it it that's what i mean i
think that's the most controversial
thing about it is some kind of therapy
or what it because eventually
as the movie unfolds you're like man
what the hell's going on here this is
some kind of supernatural thing you know
and
um he also starts weaseling his way in
between the married couple
and eventually he overcomes the husband
by
going straight for his stomach because
the [ __ ] can cook
yeah so and and she couldn't cook too
well evidently he was complaining about
her cooking
but he's making beef burgundy on and
[ __ ] well i guess she didn't really
have a lot of time to cook
because she was like taking care of the
daughter all the time yeah although he
was doing all of it yeah i guess with
two of them it was a little
a little bit less low but he was making
these uh dinners and [ __ ] so dude was
like yeah okay i guess you could stay
here
and um yeah that was all he cared about
yeah yeah
yeah i guess he said and i don't know
how much more you want to talk about uh
[ __ ] how it turns out what would be
the next thing after that well
the next thing after that you find out
later on actually you find out kind of
early on in the movie
what happened that the dad tom
is actually sort of indirectly
responsible for the truck he had hitting
the daughter
because um the daughter like turned up
at his work one day like to tell him
something
she goes into his office and finds him
like banging
the secretary secretary was riding his
ass yeah he was like on the floor yeah
turned around and looked at her watching
and she said how could you and with that
woman like there's something wrong with
it when she's just a normal woman
but it's funny they were kind of sho he
was dreaming about it too
and in his dreams not only was he
banging that secretary who she
she looked like a battle axe actually
she did actually yeah
not only was he that was another one
that was probably our age but looked at
20 years old
she looked down battle actually she was
dressed and everything too you know
and he was hitting it she was riding him
but in his mind they were showing what
he was seeing
he was imagining she was like about 20.
that was the way he saw her
remember that i think that he i think
the implication was that he wanted to
bang his daughter
so i think that wasn't his daughter
though no no i'm just saying that
he was kind of picturing someone that
was more like his daughter's age
yeah but she was about 20 right no she
was well the daughter she had been
she's in her late teens late teens early
20s because he said something about art
college yeah
so i guess she had just been out of high
school so you know in uk yeah
as a guy you know i mean i i don't
really vilify
it that much i mean you know [ __ ]
most guys actually kind of [ __ ] or
attracted to [ __ ] women in their
prime which is 20s
you know i mean that's like the pinnacle
of of it although you know some guys
expand their tastes out you know
[ __ ] to uh to to a lot of different
things than that but
the standard dude is kind of frozen
in that in that era you know what i mean
well i know that but
but that whole the whole implication the
scene where he was talking through his
daughter's yeah uh underwear drawer
would seem to imply that he kind of won
or you know that he seemed to imply that
he kind of well
yeah that the um the the martin because
he was a person martin knew about it
somehow yeah all right well because he
was he used that
to [ __ ] cuddle him into [ __ ]
submission yeah remember
yeah whether he he said i was just being
her father yeah i don't [ __ ] know
i wouldn't do that i don't have any
daughters that's weird that sounds a
little strange
uh it's a lot of strange so i don't
[ __ ] know exactly
that's [ __ ] creepy it's [ __ ]
creepy right
i think if i think they probably if they
wanted it to be
the daughter imply the daughter then
they would have used the same actress it
was a different one it was a different
girl well it but you know like i said i
think it was kind of like sublimated
because
like i said the girl that he almost
picked up when she was hitchhiking kind
of looked like his daughter as well
maybe and then he just called her a
dirty [ __ ] or whatever
dirty [ __ ] or whatever he said yeah um
most guy most
most [ __ ] your average [ __ ]
though is that's the way he thinks
and remember like when the secretary
like comes in the
comes in his office and he tells her to
like
lift her skirt up and then he says
something like that you're a salacious
jezebel oh something like that yeah and
then he goes thank you
he was something yeah
[Laughter]
he was a perv yeah he's a [ __ ] perv
yeah and that's how the devil got him
uh yeah because the devil knew what he
was yeah so
that so the daughter saw him saw him
[ __ ] banging the secretary
she wasn't really a secretary she was a
co-worker i guess that's not it's not
really made clear it does not really
make it clear
i mean that was his workplace yeah and
she [ __ ]
with that woman and she goes running
screaming out he's chasing her hold on
hold on she runs out the street get hit
by a truck
yeah well she was never able to speak
after that
so the wife never found out about it so
he kind of didn't want her
to [ __ ] regain consciousness see i
think that was implication too that
might have been not only was he guilty
about being indirectly responsible for
her getting hit by her i want to be
ratted out but also he didn't want to be
ratted out
so he was kind of hoping that she
wouldn't ever
like come back to it's it's funny you
know what i mean because i can we come
from a background you know
[ __ ] crazy-ass goths of fetish
couples that do [ __ ] weird [ __ ] and
everything you know
and uh what what this dude was about
besides
pawn through his [ __ ] daughter's
[ __ ] drawers
what the dude was about wasn't really a
big deal wasn't that unusual it was what
was unusual about him is that he had
repressed it
and somehow turned it into some kind of
a madonna [ __ ] complex
yeah that's exactly he wasn't real
honest with himself about who he was
he definitely wasn't honest with other
people and he was just like turning into
like a rage monster yeah
he was just angry he hated everybody
yeah i think like in the in
he lost all hope for in the bbc play
um they actually made him a lot worse he
was like i think he was like in the
national front or something
you know what i mean so they made him
like a lot
more of an [ __ ] he's an [ __ ] on
this one too but uh i don't
not as much as i think they softened him
a little bit although he does
that's the thing about this every
character in this
is complicated yeah like he's a dick
but the more you find out the more you
know that why he's like that
yeah you know what i mean he's he's got
sexual problems
like some other people talking about
sexual problems yeah exactly yeah well
yeah he's got problems and you know
and and his wife uh even though she's a
lovely person
but she's i mean she's not perfect
either she's still able to
i mean she basically leaves her daughter
in the care of martin
um just because she wants to get her
hair done she's over so yeah she's like
the other extreme she's like so trusting
because he's able to
you know oh you work so hard and you
haven't left this house yeah
in three years which was true she was
also kind of weak willed
yeah that too he easily pushed her
around and she was very very religious
and he used that to kind of get through
the chinks in her armor as well because
like he
you know he's the devil or a demon or
whatever there's this one
scene where she asks martin to pray over
the daughter that
to make her get better and he's like oh
okay
so you know so he goes through this big
[ __ ] like
prayer and he starts saying this [ __ ]
magnificent prayer and the [ __ ]
thunder and the lightning's [ __ ]
going on
talking to the lord and [ __ ] you know
on behalf of this
child and and the storm is happening in
there and she's just in
oh you know wow you know and then they
show outside and it's [ __ ] yeah
there's nothing there's nothing
the storm is only inside and then when
it's over
nothing happens uh i i guess
eventually would be a good way to
[ __ ] i don't know if we should spoil
it
well we already kind of did it
[Laughter]
eventually i don't remember how they
were a bit of some fight broke out
between the husband and the wife and
when that was he caused it
and i don't remember exactly what he did
and then he crept into the daughter's
room
and he started straight on just [ __ ]
climbing on top of that [ __ ] and getting
ready to bang her
oh another thing that's weird is that
during the during
him praying over her she was freaking
out right yeah
and it looked like something out of out
of the exorcist
but then they showed the internal world
what that girl was thinking
what she was thinking inside of her mind
and
she saw herself in the nightclub dancing
with cute guys
center of attention yeah that's i think
she opened heavenly she was actually in
a heavenly realm
it looked like she was suffering but she
was well yeah they were
ambiguous as to whether because i think
there's even a scene early on where
when martin comes there and she starts
reacting in a particular way
yeah and she's and the the wife says you
know oh she knows she's happy that he's
here and then
the husband says no he maybe she's
warning she's warning she's warning us
about it
you can't tell and you can't tell
because she can't talk the only time
that they
ever showed her internal world she was
partying yeah she's kind of like in a
heavenly realm
and um eventually while they're fighting
he jumps on top of her and starts
[ __ ] cracking her
and she [ __ ] comes away [ __ ] in
and uh starts screaming
the parents run in and they find him
trying to get out of the room because he
was [ __ ] really
jumped out the window jumped out the
window and then she [ __ ] wakes up and
goes daddy how could you with that woman
yeah which was the last thing that she
remembered yeah yeah so
so rape cured her yeah well
you interred here's the thing it's
ambiguous you
interpreted it as rape well it is but
that but the thing that's ambiguous
about it is whether or not he knew that
would do it
yeah you're not really yeah you're not
really sure what
his right end game is if he even has one
does he just [ __ ] with
oh we lost it no it's gone
is it okay well i lost it looks like
it's still going on here
all right you can't you couldn't tell it
was it was ambiguous
yeah you don't know if it was a devil
that had raped her or if it was an angel
that did some kind of therapy that
looked like rape that brought her back
you don't know it was all [ __ ]
ambiguous it's still going here yeah
mine's not can you guys still hear us
because
our uh the image on one it looks like
they can
frozen yeah my [ __ ] froze yeah i thought
it was good i thought it was gonna go
because my chat stopped a long time ago
yeah it did yeah no it's still going
they're saying they're all saying we're
good
yeah my chat stopped a long time yeah
it's a good it
and then there's more to it after that
but it's it it's it's a good movie and
it's kind of like a
stage play it's got really good acting
the set's good and it's got great
[ __ ] music because sting and the
police
did did all the incidental music and
stuff in the background
so you can hear a lot of like the police
andy summers playing guitar and stuff it
was good that's back
had a go-go song in it you had a go-go
song and you got beat
um because it was 82 83 this year 82 i
think it was i think you can see it for
free can't you
um well we well i bought the uh blue
rice we got the blu-ray but
i wonder if amazon prime has it i don't
know it might
um i will say that the stage play um
okay the stage play uh you know like i
said they made it in 1976
and they didn't actually show it until
1987. yeah
um but i would actually like to see that
at some point because i've heard that it
was better
you know now jenny's laptop is starting
to glitch out i still see that
everything's streaming good on my tablet
but we should shut this down now because
i think the [ __ ] stream is gonna
[ __ ]
it probably will any moment but i
recommend a movie i give it i give it a
[ __ ] five stars it's it's a classic
it's a masterpiece of what it is like
you said it's a small cast it's you know
it's very much like a stage play because
that's what it was written as um
but yeah it's like it's really really
good and i feel like a lot of people
haven't seen it maybe very ambiguous and
you could look at things in a couple
different ways
was this a natural occurrence was it
supernatural was it good was it evil
it's just everything is very clouded
you know yeah and you're not sure
exactly what you saw
like it looked like he was raping her
but the angle and everything it didn't
quite he was going to be quiet you [ __ ]
and [ __ ] like that you know
he was saying that but [ __ ] revived her
and here's the thing you see one of the
[ __ ] bible stories are elijah
it was either elisha or elijah laid on
top of a boy
to bring him back to life yeah that's
his story
well that was old testament and none of
that happened yeah it was
all mythology it was all stories he laid
on top of him and
he came alive yeah
did he lay hands on him or did he lay on
top of him it's uh it's unclear
it's just the way it was written and
like i said they leave it like that too
they leave it ambiguous as to what
stings uh
you know what what his intention was
yeah
i mean you're led to believe that he's a
demon but like you said he could be a
fallen angel as well it's a very
complicated the morality in this is very
complicated yeah
are you making it dirty because that's
the way you wanted to see it you don't
know
right yeah and i think that's i think
that's what they were trying to do yeah
definitely we're trying to [ __ ] with
your
point of view and your morality yeah uh
you don't know if you are a trusted
observer in this
yeah because the other two aren't yeah
that's true and i'm talking about
yeah nobody is all good or all about it
yeah that's kind of like what they're
that's how i
interpret it on an artistic level yeah
but yeah totally everybody should see
this it's really good like i said i
think my shit's going to crash so
we're going to uh cut it short we've
already been going 33 minutes anyway
so remember come by tomorrow because
tomorrow's wednesday at 5 00 pm eastern
standard time we're gonna do our
sidetrack show we're gonna have a drink
and talk about what the hell ever we
don't even know
we'll find out same time you guys do all
right so
thanks everybody for dropping by we will
see you guys again tomorrow evening
see you then